china has more influence in american
government
than it ever has before from the
intelligence agencies to public health
one of the few people who studied the
extent of that influence
is lee smith the author of the permanent
coup how enemies foreign and domestic
targeted the american president tucker
just sat down with him for a brand new
episode
of tucker carlson today you'll like this
part of it
the amount of damage done to the
american working class and what we're
looking at is
is absolutely shocking because if we
look at
what the biden administration now
represents
which the biden represent administration
is really at the head of a very
large american establishment again it's
not just at this point not just the
corporate and the political
establishment
but it also includes the academy all
these universities
that are taking money from the chinese
and misreporting the amount of money
that they're taking from the chinese to
basically sell their research
to basically sell their research off the
books if you look at the cultural
establishment we talk about the nba
we talk about hollywood but it's also
there's the art world as well
the art world the the the the art world
has been kept afloat
more than a decade by uh
by the chinese consumer market for if
you look at the auction houses if you
look at the different
the different galleries that still exist
now whether it's in
uh los angeles or whether it's in new
york so it just cuts across
it's just it's just an enormous streak
cutting across the middle of america
this you know what i call the china
class
it seems like a looting in some ways
but it also seems this is so depressing
i hesitate even to say it out loud but
almost like the dynamic between the
united states and great britain after
the first world war
where great british country houses were
basically dismantled and shipped to the
united states
right by some of the richest families in
the in the u.s
where you know americans married off
their daughters to
you know the children of penniless title
holders because they wanted to
etcetera etcetera etcetera but the
united states basically took a lot of
english culture and kind of shipped it
over to the us because it was an
ascendant empire
feeding on the carcass of a dying empire
right do you see any parallels no
absolutely and this is what of course a
lot of you know a lot of american
literature is about
at that point uh before world war one
and then after world war one
right it's about uh it's about the
growing it's about the growing american
uh growing american aristocracy the
business aristocracy
feeding off the uh feeding off the or or
picking off the corpse
of the british aristocracy what's
happened
here which is different is that
um again it's the american elite who
have dismantled this country and have
sold it off for parts
there was no reason for us to lose
for us to lose what is effectively a
very serious conflict between
us and china not a not a not a military
conflict
but certainly an economic one there was
no reason for us to lose it
aside from the fact that our elite was
basically
it's not even so much they were working
for the other side they were working for
their
interest and in a sense china was a
proxy they would have fed off of
anyone china happened to be the power
with a huge
captive labor force and a growing
consumer market
so i think the only difference i i think
the difference is that
the british the british aristocracy they
didn't want to
they didn't want to sell off the british
people but that's what's happened to us
our elite is uh especially corrupt
why do you think that i mean there's so
many threads here but i want to get into
the specifics in just a second but one
last big picture question
why do you think the people in charge of
the united states
were so quick to sell out their own
country i mean
was was it purely a profit motive
there does seem to be some contempt
involved
right um
in some ways the roots of it are in the
globalist idea and china really
china really is the centerpiece of the
globalist idea right you can't make
globalism
and all these other things work without
china but once you start incorporating
all these ideas like uh
trade trade is limited by things like
borders trade is limited by things like
national sovereignty
then you start having people who are
actually contemptuous
uh contemptuous of the country and and
then of course
the educational system the academy
reinforces all these different things
we've created an elite
that has no that has no that has no love
or affection for the country
that doesn't share the habits and the
mores the loves
uh as well as the hates that that that
the rest of the country
shares and once you have that people in
the leadership class
who who are openly disdainful
of the things that the rest of the
country loves and we see how they
express their contempt
lee smith the american elite has sold
this country for parts uh the whole
interview's full of stuff like that you
can watch
tucker's full show with lee smith on
tucker carlson today by
going right now to foxnation.com and you
won't regret it